here's a story from Fox News Trump
reacts after leaked recording shows him
discussing classified documents former
president tells Fox News digital he did
nothing wrong in secret document case I
have the audio here let's play it sick
people but that was your cue you know
against you well it started right when
Millie's talking about oh you were going
to try and do it no they were trying to
do that before you even were sworn in
that's right trying to overthrow your
life well with Millie uh let me see that
I'll show you an example he said that I
wanted to attack Iran
isn't it amazing I have a big pile of
papers this thing just came up look
this was him
they presented me this is off the Record
but they presented me this this was him
this was the defense department in him
we looked at some this was him this
wasn't done by me this was him and all
sorts of stuff it's pages long
wait a minute let's see here
okay
yeah I just found isn't that amazing
this totally wins my case you know
except it is like highly kind of
eventually
this is secret information look at this
you attack and Hillary would print that
out all the time you know
I should send it to Anthony Weiner
uh by the way is that incredible yeah I
was just saying because we were talking
about it and you know he said he wanted
to attack Iran and what he's in the past
this was done by the military given to
me
and you probably almost didn't believe
me but now you believe me no I believe
it's incredible so there you go that's
basically it and here's why I brought
this up for one it is it is a big story
but my point is this Hillary Clinton had
top secret information on a private
servers she had her phone smashed with
hammers and she used an open source
purging software to destroy all those
public records Comey said no reasonable
prosecutor would bring these charges Joe
Biden had classified documents in
multiple locations maybe they'll bring
charges against him doesn't seem likely
but Hillary is the really obvious one
before an election Comey said no we're
not going to do that that's ridiculous
and she wasn't even the president Donald
Trump has classified documents and they
say give him 10 years the view is is
screaming lock him up 10 years
this is the point about anything
pertaining to legality or law
it doesn't matter what you think is
right and what should be done what
matters is people with power wielded the
left certainly understands that the
right has this problem of being like you
know but is it is it allowed and the
left is just like do it anyway and
that's where we're at the Biden doj
going after Trump on charges that the
Obama doj would not bring against
Hillary Yeah well yeah I kind of want
can I ask you a few questions about this
just a lawyer absolutely so when Trump
says I could have Declassified them or
should have Declassified them is that an
admission that he didn't declassify them
properly and is that going to be held
against him well look I think that one
of the things that we're all missing is
the context of these papers that you can
hear in the background what is it that
he's actually looking at what and what
is he what is he actually flipping
through right I mean it's it's it's you
know is he flipping through some kind of
a description is he uh flipping through
some kind of a picture I mean we don't
know what was actually in front of them
but I think one of the things that
matters here is what Tim just pointed
out which was Donald Trump was the
president of the United States Hillary
Clinton was only the Secretary of State
uh you know Joe Biden the records that
he's talking about are records he got as
vice president
or previously as a senator right and so
classified documents are controlled by
the president of the United States
documents are only classified secret top
secret confidential because of an
executive order from the president of
the United States all classification
Authority derives from the president
with one limited exception set by
Congress about Atomic atomic energy
related documents and and so you have
this whole kind of that that's one angle
and a lot of people have been talking
about that but one of the things that I
think is an interesting thought that I
hope folks start to think through
is you have all this discussion right
now about
oh my goodness president Trump violated
the presidential records act and those
weren't his documents and he couldn't
have those documents those are the
people's documents and I'm sorry for me
from coming from a first principle
standpoint under the Constitution
the Congress of the United States has no
authority to tell the president of the
United States which papers are his and
which papers aren't right that is
ultimately under the Constitution the
president of the United States has to
have that power to decide which
documents are his and so if he has that
power then how can he and then he takes
those documents with him which is the
standard practice of presidents for
almost 200 years George Washington took
his papers with him after he left office
it was actually the subject of a court
case later on uh down the line but he he
deeded them to his nephew so so how is
it now that we fast forward and Congress
passes this presidential records act in
1978 Jimmy Carter signs into law and
says oh well these are all the people's
records and the president no longer has
you know kind of an ultimate say so the
president possesses the documents from
the first instance and has that absolute
authority to to do so then how can he be
prosecuted under the Espionage Act for
unlawful possession of these documents
it's insane I mean it just doesn't make
sense but not only that
first
we're gonna we're gonna find out in a
week or so that there's something more
to this video where like right after
this clip Trump goes I mean these aren't
actually any of the real documents the
real these are just you know memos it'll
be something like that right and you'll
be like oh I wonder why that context
wasn't provided because the media does
this all the time but then let's get
down to it let's get let's get down to
it first
what does this audio prove if anything
Donald Trump is an idiot maybe is that
it is it criminal it's not I I'll tell
you in two seconds Trump's legal team is
going to be like he was bragging he was
lying they're not it's not real
those are the document the papers you
hear that audio won't even real real
papers where was this audio recorded oh
it was in this room the papers were in a
different place the whole time
you you can't see anything you can't
hear anything someone's saying something
about look at these papers their secret
doesn't prove he actually had secret
papers and showed them to anybody right
so it's it's circumstantial at best it
does it is bad for Trump don't get me
wrong yeah but they're acting like it's
this big bombshell and my thing is you
know what I think I think Trump was just
speaking off the coffin and being a
braggart and then when it actually came
down to the legal matter he said look
I'm the president they're Declassified
because I say so and that's his argument
now I don't think this tape does
anything all that's going to happen is
if you're on the left you're going to
think it's a bombshell if you're on the
right you're gonna say it's stupid
as and I'll tell you this
if the left says Trump must get 10 years
for this actually they do they do let me
pull up the the little little article
here we got from mediaite lock him up
already The View gets wild as ho
suggests Trump's selling docs predict it
gets 10 years in prison okay
all right I'm down yeah you know
Hillary's next in line let's get it and
now of course we can get Obama on that
killing that 16 year old American
citizen bring them all right bring them
all let's lock them all up she said
don't buy the next he was selling
documents I mean it's just these people
are insane oh
but the point is
the reason why this tape doesn't matter
is because we know Hillary Clinton had
top secret information
we know that she had no authority to
have it we know that she had phones with
the records on them destroyed with
hammers
we know that she had uh the per the
server purged with bleach bit and Comey
said no reasonable prosecutor would
bring charges on this
so then am I supposed to think it's
reasonable for Trump to be charged no of
course not
well I'm I'm curious again as a lawyer
what do you think this does in a court
of law like this kind of evidence I mean
it it really depends on what gets
admitted and there's all kinds of tests
for what gets admitted and what gets
heard and what the the jury can see
assuming it goes to a jury
um but again Tim's exactly right his
lawyers go in and they start punching
holes in this well how do you know what
documents was he talking about do we
have witnesses who can recall and take
the stand and they'll tell Oh They'll
testify oh yeah it was this precise
document that was Mark marked top secret
no foreign uh you know your eyes only uh
document and he was showing us all of
these precise battle Plants now I mean I
I very highly doubt that in in Tim's
exactly right every time we see one of
these things play out which is I think
what the most Americans recognize now
is that every time we see one of these
allegations it's whether it's three days
or three years down the line
there's more to the story and that the
left just keeps coming at him and coming
at him and coming at him with everything
that they have and it's always this is
the last straw this is the death knell
for Donald Trump the walls are closing
the walls are closing in and every time
there's more to it Indy I think that the
left is destroying its own credibility
the more that they do this because the
average Americans sitting at home Kansas
Georgia you know Nevada wherever they
see this and they say why do they keep
going after this guy this doesn't make
sense like they just keep coming after
him it's it it just it's
counterintuitive it doesn't make any
sense to them I do want to give a
special shout out to Donald Trump for
trusting the corporate press all the
time
he just he just he just loves allowing
these people to come in all the time and
just let him record him and all this
stuff
he keeps giving them interviews it's
wonderful isn't it
I I don't get that's the part of it that
I don't get I never got it to go back to
the channel That the initial segue to
this this is my point when we were
talking about the borders and Oklahoma
Banning abortion in Colorado allowing it
it doesn't matter what you think the law
is we talked about the other day
cohabitation in West Virginia is illegal
are they going to bring charges against
you only if they want to search your
residence
show me the man I'll show you the crime
so let's say you're in West Virginia and
you're an activist and the states like
this person's causing us problems can we
find a crime that will give us a
justification for searching their
residents they're cohabitating that's
illegal boom we got them I still want to
look up that law I haven't been able to
find it so like cohabitation is in
living with someone of the opposite sex
you're not married with or in a
relationship with Boost
for like I couldn't find the law
um yeah I I agree it's not about doing
what's right but the reason I was
concerned with the whole setting up
border checkpoints thing is because I
I'm looking ahead at what problems that
could arise from a social movement to
install border patrol whether or not
it's legal whether or not it's righteous
that it could end up causing more
unnecessary spying on the the people
themselves that on you know unexpectedly
they didn't realize what they had
Unleashed on themselves by creating some
sort of patrol office around them
you try to be pulling up that law yeah
it's uh this is weird so yeah how long
is this lewd and lascivious cohabitation
when persons presumed to be unmarried is
the law 61-8-4
but it does say whether married or not
afterwards
interesting oh so like you're doing lewd
and lascivious things even within the
context of marriage they're basically
saying you're being a freak thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time